hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde heute schauen wir uns die
hunderten maus bevor faces of 2009
hinein und auf der einen seite habe ich
extrem bock auf das heutige video weil
ich mich wahrscheinlich wieder
tausendfach verlieben werde
auf der anderen seite freue ich mich
allerdings auch nicht auf das heutige
video weil die mädels wahrscheinlich
wieder einen freund haben werden wie
sollen wir uns eigentlich 100 leute
anschauen
das kriegen wir zeitlich gar nicht hin
sagt dass ich mir da nicht vorher
darüber gedanken macht ich würde sagen
wir halbieren das ganze und gucken uns
nur die 50 most beautiful faces of 2001
thiemann also hier platz nummer fünf
ich brauche jetzt schon nicht weiter
gucken aber gut das ist platz nummer 50
[Musik]
ich will mir dieses video nicht
anschauen chloe grace moretz ist auf
jeden fall auf platz 49 auf platz 48
haben wir sana sie ist sängerin und
model eine deutsche jasmin centers sind
deutschland nahm das ist sogar ihre
sechste prinz schon in diesem ranking
jasmin sogar dies deutsche muss ich
geschrieben
jasmin männer unterziehen guten tag
[Musik]
also dieses min son das ist auf platz 47
auf platz 46 haben wir barbara boll will
dies auf jeden fall auch kraß dann haben
wir gold shift.tv ani und yu jing
dies habe ich hier irgendwelche namen
falsch aus sprecher aber ich also beim
dritten platz nummer 43 wird belegt von
emilia clark ok platz 42 haben wir serra
doch gar keine ahnung was andere aber
ist platz nummer 40 und platz nummer 9
[Musik]
jba
vier monate dauern date jetzt ich
verliebt
darum mache ich mir überhaupt hoffnung
dies auf jeden fall genau mein typ weil
die extrem natürlich ist sie hier so ein
bisschen südländisch ist nicht so ganz
mein fall jahreswechsel ist die nächste
model influencer geld geld geld geld als
auch nicht so mein typ peter jung
ich weiß also wirklich soll falls die
namen falsch ausspreche den fange ich
erst gar nicht an holz entsprechender
geht's
[Musik]
berlin würde ich gern kennenlernen
mir wird dieses video hier wirklich
zahlreich zugesendet nachdem ich ja
schon vor einigen tagen auf kühler
reagiert habe und ihr ja immer noch
nicht aufhört mich und schüler bilder zu
photoshop danke übrigens dafür
vielleicht erkennen sie mich dann
irgendwann fehlen
es gibt wirklich hässlichere menschen
das heutige video hier ist wirklich
wieder komplett oberflächlich und das
tut mir leid dass ich jetzt wieder sage
aber schönheit liegt im auge des
betrachters von daher kann es natürlich
sein dass ich jetzt hier sagen die
projekte der name ist wahrscheinlich
falsch ausgesprochen ist nicht mein fall
oder hier usa ja sperre bund ist jetzt
auch nicht so meint helaba linz k auch
nicht so ganz da kann es aber natürlich
sein dass leute von euch kommentieren
und sagen mensch
die ist natürlich diesen alle hübsch
aber geschmäcker sind unterschiedlich
von einem aachener hier weiter mit
taylor mary hill ein supermodel aus
amerika was unterscheidet ein model von
einem supermodel dann sagt darauf nicht
hey ich bin fußballer und ich bin super
fußballer oder das sind youtuber mit
tausend abonnenten ein youtube es aber
einer mit einer million ist dann der
super youtuber sogar kein egoist dass
hermine emma watson ist auf jeden fall
auf 25 bei dem ranking ich wusste gleich
dass sie auch teils französische wurzeln
hat am nächsten ist solar wird die mit
so wacker betrieben ob mein gott
lockerheit einfach einmal anna van
patten ist die nächste person und hier
wir haben sehr viele personen aus dem
asiatischen raum ist mir aufgefallen
marica yamamoto wollen wir nun
allerdings auch schon zu nummer 21 dass
es handel eine türkin nummer 20 wird
belegt von einer brite namens jordan
dann heizt sie vermutlich dann haben wir
hier jenny in klammern jenny kim auch
aus korea und die nächste besonders so
lorenz
sie ist schon zum dritten mal in diesem
ranking mit dabei die nächste 70 gereimt
und ich bin ein ich bin vereint denn ich
gehe in den garten mit meinem spaten
und danach treffen
vanitas undo ist komplett falsch
ausgesprochen von miriam ist auf jeden
fall 117 platz 16 ist zulu song you're
the best actress in the world today
steht dort runter das ist die beste
honda and eight in klammern ok also ich
glaube die person die das ranking
erstellt hat ist nicht ganz objektiv an
die sache rangegangen aber okay wir
machen auf
[Musik]
wollen wir zusammen einen jacuzzi
versteht die wegen tag wie halt dein
maul guckt die euch mal an
ich sage das wirklich sehr selten okay
das ist gelogen
ich bin verliebt jersey maine mit
germanwatch auf jeden fall auf der 14
hier hat auch ein freund super aber gut
wieder positive vibes lost ist auf platz
13 auf platz
[Musik]
ich kann den namen aussprechen ob die
abra opti a brehna maximo war opti
adrina maximowitz jamin goethe
reibungslos sie belegt auf jeden fall
platz zwölf machen wir allerdings direkt
weiter mit platz nummer elf sonja panama
ok französin
[Musik]
das ist echt krass wir hatten bisher nur
eine einzige deutsche person aber
irgendwie kommt gefühlt jede zweite aus
korea oder aus frankreich
lisa soprano ist auf jeden fall die
nächste mai kabul hat es auf platz neun
man kann eigentlich too long ist
überhaupt mit dabei
josi und initiierte die lust auf seinen
doppel date du kannst du deine ganzen
früchte für oben bringen mit denen oder
kuschelt emilia
[Musik]
sie haben freut problem dass keine träne
zwiebeln emilio auf jeden fall auf platz
acht meine lieben wir brauchen
eigentlich ein bisschen mein epische
musik hier wir sind die letzten dessen
sieben mit einem hübschen der höfische
musik weiterleben freunde weiter geht es
mit nana in klammern in die nazis auf
platz 7 der hall of fame platze
dre
michelle als herr moment adriana auf
jeden fall eine kranke natürliche
schönheit also klar sie es hier auch
kraß geschminkt aber wieder auf jeden
fall so aus als wäre sie auch
ungeschminkt ein extrem schöner mensch
gottes auf platz fünf und auch gab
[Musik]
weil meine nichts freunden wie geht's
dir paribas schlimm dass nun freund hast
ist auch nicht schlimm dass du mir noch
nicht geantwortet hast hast du bestimmt
eine menge um die ordner mit halt schön
sein und so allerdings stoßen wir jetzt
auch schon vor in die richtung treppchen
meine lieben freunde also verloren hier
auf der 4 platz drei haben wir lisa aus
ich weiß nicht was das für eine frau
bereits ist auf jeden fall auch aus dem
asiatischen raum auf platz zwei haben so
eine kranke haut haben
die hat ja
die hat die hat damit also schnell
belegt auf jeden fall den zweiten platz
in diesem ranking von daher kommen wir
nun zur nummer eins meiner lieblingsfrau
[Musik]
oder dass die nummer eins
suyu hätte ich gar nicht prinz heißt
first 2009 team ok
ich hätte auf die eins gesetzt
die tür
hier das ist kein photoshop anders hätte
mich dass heute ich wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde tür lässt mich nicht los bzw
erlebt ihr euch nicht los weil ihr nicht
aufhören können mit den ganzen - und
kommentaren dazu und so viele haben ja
auch dieses video hierzu geschicktem
einen reagiere man auf die 100 most of
faces of the stars in mein team
ich gehe dann nicht ganz mit der chor
war für mich ist der all time favorite
auch mit 80 verdi da noch aber gut wir
befinden uns jetzt auf jeden fall im
auto meine lieben freunde hier oben
findet ihr einen smiley eingeblendet
werden
darauf könnt ihr einen kanal kostenlos
abonnieren wenn ich schon ab und an
einem kanal seit klickt dann auch gerne
auf die glocke dann verpasste keine
videos mehr bekommt eine
benachrichtigung sobald ich was neues
hoch laden und hier ist video verlinkt
das soeben auf einen zweiten kanal
online gegangen ist
[Musik]